und es gibt wieder neue corona-regeln
für Deutschland das ist er der Herbst
und winterplan der Bundesregierung ja
der ist nicht einfacher geworden das
sehen Sie schon an dieser massiven
Regelung hier den man ganz versucht hat
vereinfacht darzustellen und der ist
trotzdem ganz schön in sich hat also das
soll er sein Herbst und winterplan man
hat die wieder drüber geschrieben die
Winterreifen das hat sich Karl
Lauterbach ja so schön ausgedacht und
die Schneeketten also das was auf jeden
Fall kommt die Winterreifen und das was
im äußersten Notfall kommt die
Schneeketten und dann schauen wir hier
in die Regelungen mal rein die Maske die
spielt eine ganz große Rolle wieder im
Herbst und im Winter leider die FFP 2
Maske im fern und Flugverkehr soll
wieder Pflicht werden Ausnahme Personal
nur die medizinische Maske und dann in
Krankenhäusern auch da gibt es Ausnahmen
FFP 2 Maske und Test sollen Pflicht sein
aber dann nicht für die die frisch
geimpft sind oder frisch genesen sind
und dann gibt es weitere Regelungen für
den öffentlichen Nahverkehr auch dort
ffp2 maskenpflicht Personal aber nur die
medizinische Maske und in den Schulen
sieht es dann wiederum anders aus da
kommen nämlich nicht nur die Masken ins
Spiel sondern vor allen Dingen hier für
alle Schüler und Schülerinnen in
Deutschland die Tests wieder und das ist
das was wir hoffen was uns allen erspart
bleibt im Herbst und im Winter nämlich
im Grunde die Rückkehr aller
corona-maßnahmen wieder Abstandsgebot
Hygienekonzepte personenobergrenze
Veranstaltung in Innenräumen wieder nur
noch eine Binder bestimmten
Personenanzahl all das droht schon
wieder hier auf diesem neuen corona-plan
der Bundesregierung also man guckt sich
nicht besonders gerne an und trotzdem
muss man einmal drauf geschaut haben die
Bundesregierung plant massiv mit
maskenpflicht und auch wieder mit
weiteren corona-maßnahmen für Herbst und
für Winter
[Musik]